for its fourth installment the insidious
franchise takes another step back in
time we see one of the least Rainiers
earliest childhood experiences with the
other side a Nomi seer was a full-grown
ghost hunter who's made to revisit her
past in cruel and surprising ways while
the story is mostly a standalone
adventure for the spiritual psychic the
last key still draws on the mythology of
the series and features some of the
central players of the franchise in fun
and fresh new ways let's take a look at
how insidious the last key explores
Elise's devastating backstory and wraps
things up on a note of continuity
pattern of possession in childhood Alise
is tormented by more than just the
spirits that occupy her family home her
prison guard father is also heavy-handed
with punishments to the point of abuse
clearly deranged he insists he can beat
the ghostly visions out of her and fears
her supernatural gifts summons back to
the property in her later years by the
homes new occupant Ted Gaza she
discovers he's kidnapped and tortured a
woman in the basement for months he
claims as something as invaded his mind
but he still ultimately done away with
by specs afterwards Alise continues to
explore and uncover more terrible
secrets about the history of the home
including her own father similar
abduction and the slaughter of a woman
in that very spot Alise realizes both
men were possessed by the demon that
terrorized her in her youth and instead
of getting revenge on her ghost dad in
the further she decides not to feed the
demon herself it's not clear that's all
of her father's bad behaviors were due
to the demonic force but he does
apologize to her in Ghost form before
withering back into his spiritual cell
weapon of love the true big bad of the
movie is a key monster Elise first runs
into it in childhood after her father
banishes her to the basement with a
voice summoning her to a keyhole that
unlocks the door to the demons lair her
mother is the first true victim of that
mistake as she attempts to rescue Elise
from the basement but is instead
strangled by the nefarious spirits while
Elise remains in a state of demonic
hypnosis her mother's passing is a
tragedy for Elise and her brother a
woman loving parent she'd giving him a
whistle to blow if he ever felt scared
of Elise's sightings as we see in
Elise's older years the whistle was lost
for decades but it pops up drawing her a
return to the old home and it's used by
tortured spirits to guide her through
to battle since the key demon deprives
his victims of the ability to speak when
Elise confronts a demon in his lair Hale
maneuvers her and deprives her of her
voice too but she finds a whistle in
time to summon the spirit of her mother
who's able to vanquish the Beast through
the sheer power of her love and light
it's not clear if Elise's mother will
ever escape the otherworldly prison
below the house but she does seem at
peace when at least two parts coaching
herself one of the most surprising
encounters at least experiences during
her time and the further is when she
runs into herself as a child in the
basement she doesn't tell the child
version of herself who she is but does
insist that younger least use her gifts
to help people despite her father's
tyrannical treatment if only she'd been
able to tip off the child that the girl
she spots in the laundry room at the age
of sixteen is very real she might have
been able to save Anna alas she does at
least encourage her to use her
nightmares for the betterment of the
world and to never back down from demons
otherworldly or otherwise the family
business
although release his brother is none too
thrilled to see her again
decades after she'd escaped their
father's menacing clutches he doesn't
have a choice but to welcome her when
she rescues his daughters after a lease
informs Christian that she found his old
whistle in the home he decides her relic
is important enough to track down
problem is his youngest daughter melissa
is summoned down to the basement by the
key demon who makes short order of
adding Elise's knees to its collection
of victims Elise senses the attacker
returns to the property
promising to find her after she's
temporarily incapacitated below though
the other sister Imogen decides to try
her own hand at psychic work and is
lowered into a state of hypnosis by
Tucker inspects I can see thanks to
she's there on a rescue mission but it's
the least who ultimately leads the two
girls back to safety and Christian is
grateful for our salvation of his
daughters meanwhile Imogen is now
trapped into her own paranormal gifts
and Elise's legacy can maybe live on
through another generation and that
that's very very important to the
franchise as a whole because the movie
finishes with a direct link to the
timeline of the original insidious
movies Elise dreams about a boy named
Dalton being haunted by the red-faced
demon we come to know so well in the
earlier installments and sees Renee and
Josh lying in bed and lamenting the
unknown that's troubling their child
Elise awakens to receive a call from
Lorraine who reminds her that she helped
us
Josh as we saw in the flashback events
of insidious - and now the same thing is
happening to Dalton that's the catalyst
for the events of the first insidious of
course when a lease helps Dalton escape
from the further only to be strangled by
Josh who's been possessed by the same
demon that haunted him as a child
insidious - left off worthily still
working her demon battling magic
following Tuckerman specs - new
spiritual assignments but with the added
element of image earn a new medium who
can work with a lease on the earthy
plane but ghost busting business might
not be done for for the insidious team
just yet thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check all this cool stuff
we know your loved team